there's so much about these numbers that
you don't understand unless you take a
step back so I'm gonna take a big step
back I'm gonna go all the way back to
the beginning of dumpers I think the
beginning of those numbers are just like
what video see and writing and all that
kind of thing they are relatively
speaking modern invention of mankind
okay numbers haven't existed for the
amount of time that humanity exists it
was an introduced idea okay but wherever
we have recordings of numbers appearing
numbers always begin in the same context
they always begin in the same context
and that context is counting okay now
counting is still something that is
evident like the fact that numbers
started with counting is still evident
in a lot of things that you take for
granted for example oh boy big new Bruce
let me get most right the first three
numbers are in 1 2 3 right you can see
that counting is built into the
representation all of our numbers right
representation of numbers and it's not
just the ribbons such as notes in fact
more or less every counting system and
all the symbols that we use for example
the Chinese scripts and the Japanese
script this on it looks like this 1 2 3
nice it's got the same pattern of
counting built into it and in fact our
numbers yes therefore is interesting for
is a little more gets our for another
time but I just want you to notice I
just want you to notice that 1 2 & 3 in
this script is not all that different
for one let me just draw it to make it
really obvious and
three in our script it's not that
different it's just that you've been
thinking so long of one and two and
three as their own things that you've
sort of not remembered that counting is
where they begin question
okay and move on now here's the problem
/ you never I said it numbers begin with
counting but very rapidly very rapidly
numbers do not end there in fact if you
take these numbers we call them they're
natural numbers or the counting numbers
it's pretty obvious to see that the
natural numbers are not the only kinds
of numbers there are the counting
numbers sort of give rise to all these
other kinds of numbers for instance very
simple situations if you've got like a
whole number of objects a counting
number of days and a whole number of
people or groups if you want to separate
the natsu or share them into you quickly
realize that they don't each get a whole
or a counting number of pizza slices
right 8 into 3 it doesn't go neatly goes
into two goes into four goes into one
right but does it go into three new
numbers have to be introduced right in
the same way very quickly the Greeks
realized that even if you've got whole
number links here and yeah what you get
out here is a different kind of number
again it's not another kind of number
like this it's not a ratio it's
something different but it argued for a
long time as to what it was but they
knew it wasn't like these guys
it wasn't the county number one rational
man and so on okay so this whole history
of the development of numbers is really
about well you start here everyone
starts here but when you start to
combine these in different ways you
start to realize one two three four then
not enough okay so let's think about
this in a systematic way
drop this table if your lies doesn't
have to be being what we're doing here
like starting the counting and they're
talking about division that's what this
is isn't it
or talking about these links and so on
what binds all these ideas together is
that we manipulate them through algebra
we manipulate them through the laws and
rules of algebra and the operations okay
so what we're going to put together here
is a series of algebraic equations we're
going to use these familiar counting
numbers those round building blocks and
you'll see if we combine them in ways
and you already know about these ways
mostly if we combine them with plus
minus times divide and indices
exponentiation which is very very
similar
not entirely identical but bracelets the
idea of your PIN in multiplication right
if you just take these five algebraic
operations right then you will see all
of these different kinds of numbers they
pull out I would give you some language
and some own some notation to describe
this okay so for instance if we think of
a simple equation like X take away five
equals zero basic question for you okay
it has an answer there's a solution to
this right or rich if you like right the
solution of course to X minus five
equals zero is it's x equals five good
thanks okay so this is that simple
example this is still back in this
region of counting numbers right but I
want to get some more fine language of
notation on this because as we've talked
about the four language is power
once you know how to describe something
which you have language to describe it
you do understand it manipulated
interpret and so on so these counting
numbers are technically a form of are
the natural numbers and natural numbers
and we have a symbol for it I have
showed it to you before I think it's an
end read extra lines on it
infinite natural all right that's pretty
simple that's it that's an out counting
number world but it's pretty easy to get
out of the counting of the world for
instance if I give you an equation like
this which is just as simple just as
simple what's the solution
x equals negative two right so we are
pretty quickly like I haven't even gone
plus a dish past addition and
subtraction right I'm out of the
counting number world already right now
negative 2 is not a county number it's
not any natural number in the technical
sense of the word we have another name
for this starts with an i we call the
integers okay now for reasons that will
become clear a second even though the
name of it is integers we don't use an
eye yeah we use the character Zed which
we get from the Germans it's from the
it's an abbreviation of the jury with
Sol which means ironically it's counting
anyway these the integers that's the
name that's the symbol that you will see
attached to integers all right now we
went past the net for numbers we weren't
past integers if we stay weird using the
counting numbers to construct this thing
for instance again another simple
equation something like this what is
this solution so this algebraic equation
x equals 1/2 right x equals 1/2 now this
is still in familiar familiar territory
for us this is a rational number okay
it's a ratio between 1 & 2 a symbol for
this again for reasons that are come
clear in a second we do not use our
rational we use a cube which stands for
not rational but what word has to do
with yeah thank you
pushes right this is a division number
because that's kind of where it begins
when we get these reference numbers
wrong choose the question okay now
there's one last category all about
numbers that we've been dealing with
over the last many number of users okay
and I can quickly come up with a
solution an equation that will give me
this something like say let's do this so
I've gone to exponentiation here so I've
got an index but importantly all of my
numbers that I've used to build my
equations they're all counting numbers
right
like these are doing other building
blocks but you can buy them in simple
way so you get reader different numbers
over here what is the solution or rather
what are the solutions to this equation
okay so x equals plus or minus the
square root of five okay now square
roots where the number that's underneath
the square root
is it a square number these are not
rational numbers you can't write them is
their fraction but that's equal to right
at least their fraction that's just
built with catching numbers so therefore
this is a different kind of Papa it's
irrational right but more widely
speaking it belongs to this class of
numbers a real numbers okay so we've
been talking about this for a long time
we talked about quadratics that have
real solutions or don't have real
solutions let's just take us a long way
where you can do a lot of maths with
real numbers okay but it doesn't quite
take us all the way
think about algebraic equations right
and these simple tools that we'll be
using to build solutions right